Fire Department police department and
emergency management responded quickly
to the scene and we are working closely
with Con Ed to restore power as quickly
as possible we have no reports of
injuries or fatalities at this time we
also have a list of those individuals
that are on life-saving equipment and we
are working with them to make sure they
have what they need then we have put
together a joint task force with PD in
the fire department to make sure that
nobody is stuck in an elevator still
right now I'd like to turn it over to
the CEO of Con Ed McEvoy to give an
update from Con Ed
I could evening thank you very much my
name is John McAvoy appear to represent
con Edison we experience a significant
disturbance on the west side of
Manhattan at one of our electric
transmission stations at roughly 650
46:47 p.m.
that eventually interrupted power to
approximately 73,000 customers we
divided the electric system into what we
call networks roughly equivalent in
neighborhoods it interrupted power to
six network
we expedited the recovery performed an
initial assessment of what was the most
likely cause isolated that equipment
inspected the other important thing to
identify any any obvious abnormalities
and now we have we have started the
restoration process
of the six networks that we've lost
we've restored two of those networks
starting from just before 10:00 p.m. and
we are working to restore the remaining
four networks by midnight and
now there were some unknowns in this as
we restore equipment we wait we may find
damage that were not currently aware of
but we are proceeding on a path to
restore or customers hopefully quite
midnight tonight
we'll then look at her
the group forces of the event and
restore the system to a fully normal
condition once we understand exactly
what occurred and what for is the
outages the world experience
back aboard you know exactly why this
happened it's not that's been especially
hot day and thankfully it's a Saturday
in which businesses have people aren't
in their offices right it does not
appear related to excessive load as
sometimes has occurred in the past when
we when we have an incident like this we
focus first on isolation of the failed
equipment or the most likely and
restoration of the customers and then
when customers really move a full route
for his investigation to identify what
may enforce
[Music]
so I can't speak to the explosions that
they may have heard when you have
incidents like this launch circuit
breakers which are they the high voltage
equivalent of circuit breakers in a
panel in the house operate and they are
very loud with the operator that could
have been what they heard but I can't
know for sure because the world
restoration attempts pay
so I did hear a report of a fire in the
manhole we'll investigate
very unlikely that a fire in a manhole
was the cause of an incident of this
gift this has happened occasionally in
our city even from some out of the
winter it's ice
yet really not evil to it what could
have caused this we have to go through
the full engineering analysis to look at
the data the facts of the important
condition to identify the force
how many networks the back where we had
two out of six back we've got a
definitely a third out of six
we have five of the six networks
restored one network remains to
Pennsylvania Network which is roughly
42nd Street and 32nd street team at
Hudson River to roughly Broadway 17
good evening I'm chief Steve you is on
the commanding officer of Manhattan
south we did a level three mobilization
bringing units from around the city the
effective area was 42 to 72 from 50
every to the west side we implemented a
vehicle traffic freeze we just like city
buses up at that point you stopping
civilian traffic and going we're in a
process of bringing all the units in the
post offices around on each of the
blocks so there is a significant uniform
presence out there
[Music]
we appreciate their assistance I heard
reports New York one had a gentleman
that overly general when it came out
assistant traffic but you know how big
part of purpose was to stop the traffic
I'm coming into the area and that's what
we were focusing on
it's 42 years ago time tonight w had to
blackout so tonight a totally different
situation people came together and we
handle it pretty well
I'd like to just thank everybody for
coming out here tonight as you can see
we have
network that is still down we are going
to continue to work closely together
with PD and Fire and con Edison we'll
get that up as soon as possible that
cooperation here has been excellent
that's why we've been able to get it
restored as quickly as we have and thank
you again very much we have a task force
that has been going to all of the
affected buildings to make sure that
nobody was in elevators
I have not gotten any reports at this
moment but we have a task force that's
definitely going bowling the building
for those
sorts of injuries so there's sort of
thing
there were no reports of injuries or
fatalities and I have been personally in
touch with the mayor to give him an
update on this